OUR BREAKING NEWS THIS HOUR, A
JURY HAS JUST FOUND STEVE BANNON
GUILTY ON BOTH COUNTS OF
CRIMINAL CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
THE FORMER TRUMP STRATEGIST
FACES A MANDATORY MINIMUM OF 30
DAYS IN JAIL.
>> CNN'S SARA MURRAY JOINS US
NOW FROM THE COURTHOUSE.
WE'RE ALSO JOINED BY ELIE HONIG
AND NICK ACKERMAN HERE.
TELL US WHAT'S JUST HAPPENED IN
THE COURTROOM?
>> Reporter: WELL, STEVE BANNON
HAS BEEN FOUND GUILTY ON TWO
COUNTS OF CRIMINAL CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS.
HE SMILED AND SMIRKED.
MY COLLEAGUE KATELYN POLANTZ
SAYS WHEN THE VERDICT WAS READ.
SHE WAS IN THE COURTROOM AS THIS
WAS HANG.
THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF
STRATEGIST IS AS DEFIANT AS
EVER.
WITH THE CONVICTION, HE FACES 30
DAYS BEHIND BARS AT A MINIMUM,
AS WELL AS POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS OF FINES.
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY.
THE JUDGE HAS SET OCTOBER 21st
AS THE SENTENCING DATE.
IT WILL BE A FEW MONTHS BEFORE
WE KNOW WHAT SENTENCE IS GOING
TO BE HANDED DOWN.
IT'S BEEN CLEAR FROM BANNON'S
ATTORNEYS THROUGHOUT THIS TRIAL
THAT THEY DO INTEND TO APPEAL.
BECAUSE THESE ARE MISDEMEANOR
CHARGES IT'S VERY POSSIBLE THAT
WE COULD SEE THE JUDGE DELAY ANY
KIND OF, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
BANNON HAS TO SERVE ANY KIND OF
SENTENCE UNTIL AFTER THEY GO
THROUGH THAT APPEALS PROCESS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW THAT YET.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THIS IS A BIG
BOOST TO THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE.
THIS IS A REAFFIRMATION OF THEIR
INVESTIGATIVE POWER, OF THEIR
SUBPOENA POWER, AT A TIME WHEN
THEY'RE WRANGLING WITH A BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT WITNESSES.
PETER NAVARRO IS ANOTHER PERSON
WHO DEFIED HIS SUBPOENA AND IS
POISED TO GO TO TRIAL OVER THAT.
IT'S A WIN FOR THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
THEY'VE COME UNDER A LOT OF
SCRUTINY, CRITICISM IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY'RE INVESTIGATING THE
JANUARY 6TH ATTACK ON THE
CAPITOL.
I THINK PEOPLE HAVE WANTED TO
SEE, YOU KNOW, MORE FROM THEM IN
A NUMBER OF CASES.
IN THIS CASE, THEY GOT A VERY
PROMINENT CONVICTION.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SARA, STAY WITH US, I WANT TO GO
TO NICK JUST JOINING THE PANEL.
YOUR REACTION TO THE GUILTY
VERDICT.
>> I THINK IT'S EXTREMELY
SIGNIFICANT, AND THE REASON,
REALLY IS IN LIGHT OF WHAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY IN THE HOUSE
HEARING.
WHAT WE FOUND THERE WAS ON THAT
DAY, ON JANUARY 6TH, DONALD
TRUMP WAS BEGGED, WAS ASKED
REPEATEDLY BY PEOPLE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, EVERYONE AROUND
HIM, INCLUDING HIS FAMILY TO
TELL HIS SUPPORTERS TO GO HOME,
TO STAND DOWN, AND TO LEAVE THE
CAPITOL.
AND WHAT YOU FIND HERE IS THAT
WHO WERE THE PEOPLE THAT WERE
EGGING HIM ON, WHO WERE THE
PEOPLE THAT REALLY PUSHED THIS
ENTIRE, YOU KNOW, PLAN OF
VIOLENCE, AND OBVIOUSLY STEVE
BANNON COMES TO LIGHT AS THE
FIRST PERSON ON THE LIST.
I MEAN, HE WAS IN CHARGE OF THE
WAR ROOM AT THE WARWICK HOTEL.
THIS IS WHERE ALL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO WERE REALLY NOT GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, ROGER STONE, RUDY
GIULIANI, HIS CHIEF
INVESTIGATOR, OFF OF THESE
PEOPLE WERE CENTERED AROUND
THERE.
NONE OF THEM GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES, NONE OF THEM WERE
LIKE MATTHEW WOPARRING JER WHO
SAID I TOOK AN OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
NONE OF THESE PEOPLE TOOK AN
OATH.
THESE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE
AROUND DONALD TRUMP AND
BASICALLY DOING HIS BIDDING.
THE FACT THAT ONE OF THE CHIEF
ARCHITECTS OF JANUARY 6TH WAS
CONVICTED TODAY ON THESE TWO
CHARGES I THINK IS EXTREMELY
SIGNIFICANT.
>> AND WE'VE LEARNED THAT THERE
WERE THOSE TWO CALLS BETWEEN
STEVE BANNON AND FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST BEFORE ON
HIS WAR ROOM PODCAST HE SAID,
ALL HELL WILL BREAK LOOSE
TOMORROW, AND THAT'S WHAT THE
COMMITTEE WANTED TO KNOW, WHAT
HE KNEW LEADING UP TO THAT
STATEMENT.
>> BUT EVEN FURTHER, WE HAVE THE
OTHER LITTLE BITS OF DETAIL THAT
CAME OUT DURING THE COURSE OF
THE HEARINGS.
>> YEAH.
>> ONE, THAT THERE WAS A
TELEPHONE CALL FROM THE CHIEF OF
STAFF OF DONALD TRUMP TO ROGER
STONE.
NOW, WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
WE DON'T KNOW WHO WAS TALKING TO
WHOM, BUT WE KNOW ROGER STONE
WAS ALSO AT THE WARWICK HOTEL.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT HE WAS
ASKED -- THE CHIEF OF STAFF OF
WAS ASKED TO TO THE WARWICK
HOTEL, AND IT TOOK SOMEONE LIKE
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON TO SAY LOOK,
YOU SHOULDN'T BE GOING THERE,
AND HE STILL WENT BY PHONE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS SAID
THERE, BUT THERE WAS A WHOLE
BUNCH OF TANTALIZING LITTLE
DETAILS THAT CAME OUT IN THE
COURSE OF THAT HEARING THAT MAKE
YOU WONDER WHAT WAS GOING ON AT
THE WARWICK HOTEL.
>> BUT ELIE, DOES THIS MAKE IT
HARDER FOR THE COMMITTEE TO GET
THE INFORMATION THEY WERE
SEEKING FROM STEVE BANNON, THE
REASON, JUST TO REMIND EVERYBODY
THAT HE WAS JUST FOUND GUILTY IS
BECAUSE HE DIDN'T HAND OVER
DOCUMENTS AND HE DIDN'T SHOW UP,
THOUGH HE WAS SUBPOENAED.
WILL THEY EVER GET TO SEE THE
INFORMATION THAT THEY WANTED NOW
THAT HE'S BEEN CONVICTED?
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE, THIS
IS ABOUT PUNISHMENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT FORCING
SOMEBODY TO TESTIFY.
STEVE BANNON WILL NOT TESTIFY
UNLESS HE JUST HAS A UNILATERAL
CHANGE OF HEART.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT WIN FOR DOJ
AND FOR CONGRESS BUT IT'S A
QUALIFIED WIN.
HERE'S WHY.
STEVE BANNON IS BEING PUNISHED
NOW BECAUSE HE DEFIED A
CONGRESSIONAL SUBPOENA.
DOJ CHARGED HIM, THEY GOT THEIR
CONVICTION.
THAT'S THE WIN, BUT THERE'S
STILL A BIT OF A MIXED MESSAGE
HERE.
DOJ CHOSE NOT TO CHARGE MARK
MEADOWS THEY CHOSE NOT TO CHARGE
DAN SCAVINO.
STEVE BANNON IS GOING TO FEDERAL
PRISON, UNLESS HE WINS ON
APPEAL, WHILE MARK MEADOWS AND
DAN SCAVINO DID THE SAME THING,
PROVIDED THE SUBPOENA, THEY LEFT
THE GAPS IN THE EVIDENCE THAT
NICK WAS TALKING ABOUT AND THEY
ARE WALKING SCOT-FREE BUT BETTER
THAT SOMEBODY IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE THAN NOBODY.
>> SARA, LET ME COME BACK OUT TO
YOU.
IT WAS A LAST DITCH EFFORT, SOME
VIEWED IT AS A WAY TO AVOID THIS
TRIAL BY TELLING THE COMMITTEE,
I WILL PARTICIPATE, I WILL
COOPERATE.
DOES THIS CONVICTION PRECLUDE
ANY FUTURE PARTICIPATION WITH
THAT COMMITTEE NOW?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, I THINK
THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES ALWAYS
AROUND THIS CASE IS THAT
AGREEING TO TESTIFY WAS NEVER
GOING TO SOLVE HIS CRIMINAL
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS CHARGES.
WE HEARD FROM THE PROSECUTION
TODAY, GIVE ME A BREAK, WHY IS
HE SUDDENLY MAKING THIS OFFER IN
THE DAYS LEADING RIGHT UP TO HIS
TRIAL.
PROSECUTORS SORT OF CAST THIS AS
AN INSINCERE EFFORT AND SAID HE
HASN'T EVEN STARTED, YOU KNOW,
HANDING OVER DOCUMENTS, WHICH IS
ONE OF THE THINGS HE HAS BEEN
FOUND GUILTY OF.
THEY SAW IT AS A PLOY.
IF YOU'RE STEVE BANNON AT THIS
POINT, AND YOU ARE NOW CONVICTED
OF THESE TWO COUNTS, YOU SORT OF
WONDER, WHAT IS THE IMPETUS TO
BE AT ALL HELPFUL TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THE REALITY IS THEY MAY NEVER
GET THE INFORMATION THAT THEY
WERE SEEKING FROM STEVE BANNON,
AND I THINK, YOU KNOW, THE
WILLARD HOTEL CONVERSATION YOU
WERE JUST HAVING IS A GOOD
EXAMPLE OF THAT.
THE COMMITTEE MADE CLEAR THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THEY WANTED TO
HEAR FROM STEVE BANNON IS WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN THIS SORT OF WAR
ROOM THAT HE AND OTHERS WERE
PARTICIPATING IN AT THE WILLARD
HOTEL, AND WE HAVE HEARD VERY
LITTLE OF THAT IN THESE PUBLIC
HEARINGS FROM THE JANUARY 6TH
COMMITTEE.